well I'm pleased to say that Gabriel
Clark is joining me now with his dad
Richard great to have you both with us
um Gabriel yeah happy Easter happy
Easter and that's the latest bowl that I
can see you holding just there give us a
look at it Gabriel
yeah here we go you're very talented
when you first uh try to fundraise last
year did you have any idea how it was
going to go and and how did you feel
when you realized quite how much you'd
made oh it was absolutely incredible I
no idea that it would be so um magical
and it would go so big it's all Parma
dad's tweet that really um took it off
but I've had so many amazing experiences
because of it
well just to remind our viewers Gabriel
you made a carved wooden Bowl last year
if I'm not mistaken correct me if I get
anything wrong here
um and you put it up for raffle to raise
money to help Ukrainian children and you
raised quarter of a million pounds is
that right that is that is right yeah I
carved a wooden Bowl called the ball for
Ukraine and raffled it for safe
children's Ukraine appeal and in around
two weeks we've raised and just over a
quarter of a million which is absolutely
amazing
two weeks you raise that amount of money
in two weeks tell me what was what was
the atmosphere like in your household
Richard is that money just grew and grew
well it was it was it was all nuts
really it's sort of the story kicked off
sort of thing so the fundraiser last
year's sort of carried on on the back of
some interesting Gabriel and his
woodwork uh and we had no idea and it
just uh largely through social media it
just went viral and it and it went all
around the world we even had clips from
Korean TV uh uh showing the bowl and the
making of the bowl but what's nice is
Gables you know it was great his Gables
decide we know it was one-off last year
but he really wanted to go at it again
because uh uh kids still need help out
there sort of thing so um this is his
latest fundraiser The Hope Bowl
yeah very much so now Gabriel you
traveled to Warsaw to meet uh Ukrainian
children who have been evacuated and are
now living there what was that like
I it was amazing to be honest at first I
was really quite nervous I didn't want
to say the wrong thing but I walked in
and everyone's English was so incredible
and they were so kind uh we spent the
whole day sort of playing games and
um having chats I got absolutely
thrashed and I gave a table tennis we
painted
um wooden Easter egg so she said
tradition in Ukraine but we did um we
did so much amazing stuff it was great
now we're looking at some pictures at
the moment of a wooden Bowl being
received by
um someone that you you gave it to can
you tell us about that who is that
that is the head teacher of the school
she's an absolutely remarkable woman
and I just thought I would give her one
of her bowls to show my um appreciation
for letting me have a look around the
school
it must have been quite an emotional
trip for you
um what did what did you learn on that
trip what did some of the children tell
you about how life is for them now
um I didn't want to speak too much about
um the war and stuff as not to upset
them but they seemed um they seemed just
like me they were so passionate about
all sorts of things they are all
um just your average children
but I think that's what shocked me the
most really is how the war has affected
them of course but the fact that there's
still just lovely normal children
and just briefly do you know what your
money has gone towards in helping these
children
um the 250 000 pounds from last year
um has gone towards setting up equipment
for the school
um setting up tents around Ukraine food
um
food entertainment games toys everything
that child needs to stay happy really
and this is probably schools wasn't it
with from 500 kids in each that have
been supported by the money that
everybody gave last year
oh wow and and this time you're raising
money for save the children children
um more widely is that right
yeah so this year we're um raising money
for safe children's emergency fund we've
raised around 17 000 so far and I'm
hoping to take that up because there's
so many children around the world that
really need all the support they can get
some of the money will still go to
Ukraine and stuff but it's uh it's a
it's a fun but when a crisis hits they
can get money straight away to kids that
really need it and the war has affected
kids in in because the cost of the crane
has really in fact hits as far as East
Africa and places so we really wanted to
spread the love a bit wider this year
yeah so we'd love people to give if they
go to The Gables just giving page please
please consider making a little donation
this Easter to the Hope Bowl and you can
win it uh was it next Friday so we're
going to randomly randomly choose
someone that's donated next Friday and
they will win the amazing Hope Bowl
which is a really really beautiful
well thank you so much for coming on uh
to share your story with us uh Gabriel
you are quite a talent and doing
something really important and
impressive at such a young age and
Richard congratulations what a wonderful
human being you've got there at happy
Easter thank you happy Easter guys thank
you very much